hello everyone this game comes as a
request from a subscriber and as the
title would suggest it is well the most
amazing draw ever played it was played
between Carl Hampi and the Philip
Meitner compa was a Swiss Austrian chess
master also a Swiss government official
and he won won the Vienna Championship
twice both times ahead of William
Steinitz and the Philip Meitner was also
a chess master and a lawyer so both of
them pretty strong players and the game
itself it's well it's like something out
of a science fiction novel you'll just
have to see it for yourselves
so Carl humppa has the white pieces and
he plays efore we have e5 Knight to c3
and Bishop to c5 the Anderson defense
and here we have a move that will after
this game be known as the hump a Meitner
variation of the Vienna game Knight to
a4 forcing this dark-squared bishop to
either retreat to e7 or maybe d6 the
block is owned upon but white would
definitely like to like to exchange his
Knight for the bishop for example if
black played Bishop to b6 but of course
white is practically inviting black to
sacrifice the bishop on f2 and it's not
really even a sacrifice so black can
easily win the piece back so he does
Bishop captures an f2 is played King
captures an f2 and here we have a Queen
to h4 with check and what do you do here
if you play a move like g3 to block the
check you get Queen captures on e4 with
the attack on the rook on h1 and also
with the attack on the night on a4 white
is well either winning the rook or the
night either way black is better here so
after this Queen to h4 move black a
white King decided to boldly go to e3
and guard the e4 pawn himself we have
Queen to f4 with Czech and now if you
play a move like King - E - you get
Queen captures on e4 again winning the
piece back and well with the White King
being on e - that's just silly
so after Queen to f4 King the d3 was
played and now black plays d5
if you play a move like yeah eek after
sandy five again you allow Queen to the
forecheck followed by Sun Bishop to g4
ideas also you're allowing black to
capture the piece back and well I mean
look a look at the White King much
better for black
so after this d5 move White gets a plan
that he will play his King all the way
to b3 play a three and then make an
escape route for the King on a two and
maybe go to b1 and hide so he plays King
to c3 we have Queen captures on e4 and
now King Tubby 3 and now White's idea is
to play Knight to c3 maybe get the
knight back into the game with a tempo
and maybe consolidate but black doesn't
allow this night to a6 is played and
this stops the idea of Knight to c3 with
the simple Queen to b4 checkmate this
would be very unfortunate for mr. Carl
so after 92 a6 he played a 3 now
stopping any Queen to b4 ideas and if
white if white was able to play Knight
to c3 and consolidate with King to a 2
this might even be playable for white
this would be quite a king walk but why
not but black had enough of this he said
that's what this was a brave King March
but he's not going to allow this night
to get away and he plays Queen captures
on a4 he sacrifices the Queen if you
decline the Queen wouldn't move like
King to a2 black got back the piece and
well again he's just better so you do
have to you don't have to capture the
Queen King captures an a4 and now we
have night the c5 with check the night
is now checking the White King and also
covering the be three square so the King
cannot escape with be three and a two we
have King two before and now a5 is
played and well does the white really
have an option here he can go to c3
maybe but that would result in a very
quick draw
if for example King to c3 then d4 check
came to c4 and then b6
Queen to f3 with an attack on the rook
and now Bishop to e6 would check King to
b5 Bishop to d7 would check King to c4
Bishop d6 would check and so on so
definitely a drone a drone variation so
after a five white decides to go in for
even further with the King and play King
captures on c5 so King captures and c5
is played and now Knight to e7 black is
defending the d5 pawn and now his pawns
are protecting efore d4 c4 and B 4 so
the King is cut off all the way to the
other half of the board we have Bishop
to b5 with the check and now King to d8
and here if why it's not careful black
will play b6 and this will be checkmate
because the night is covering the c6
square and Bishop to c6 is played this
is the only move this stops this
checkmate you you have to give up the
bishop to make room for King unbe 5 we
have b6 now and kink the b5 is played
what happens well nothing happens
because you can't really play anything
else so so King to b5 we have Knight
captures on c6 King captures on c6 and
Bishop to b7 inviting the white king to
go in even further into this position
but if the scheme captures the bishop on
b7 this would be very unfortunate for
him as if King capture some b7 you get
King to d7 now the threat is rook H to
b8 with checkmate and you can prolong
this what maybe
Queen to g4 would check but after King
to d6 there are no more useful checks
and well rook H to be 8 is unstoppable
so after Bishop to b7 check white saw
that he can't really accept this nice
Bishop on b7 so he played King to b5 and
here mister Meitner might not get
another idea he plays Bishop to a6 check
now and well what do you play here you
can go back to c6 but then you get
Bishop to b7 again resulting in a draw
so black offered white to try
and play this game by playing kink to a
four but this would be a terrible
mistake because after Bishop to c4 there
is no defense against b5 checkmate
whatever you play for example B 3 or B 4
doesn't really matter
black seem to place B 5 and this comes
with checkmate
so after Bishop to a6 white played the
King to c6 and we have Bishop to b7
check again and in this position players
agreed to a draw and well so the mortal
draw game was created so quite a
fascinating game and I really like that
well this is today known as the as the
Meitner humper variation or the hump it
might not variation and well I'm sure
there are a lot of enjoyable draws but
this one really really tops everything
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here I think y'all
for watching and I will see you soon and
if any of you are able to find a decent
photo of mr. might now or call humppa
please do share in the comment section
so I can replace the thumbnail photo
thank you all and I'll see you soon